so first if you had the opportunity to
swap roles with anybody in any of the
Star Wars films who would you pick and
why
Lando's is is exactly what appeals to me
I'm surprised you're the only person who
actually embraced their character and
didn't opt to swap with someone no it
was that that character allowed me to do
some things that I enjoy doing in terms
of developing a character you know
between the cave and the name Calrissian
is the word the two key factors that
that helped me develop this whole
persona are there any techniques that
you picked up playing Lando back in
empire the first film that you brought
with you to all of your other work
whether it was Star Wars or something
completely different
well the most important thing to me when
I do these characters or whatever the
character happens to be is that it it's
not pin pigeon-holed it's a character
that has a lot of depth in the end and a
character that's bigger than life that's
how I try to what I try to bring to my
characters that respect yeah they're
very universal can you tell me a little
bit about working with both George and
JJ on this character well they're both
brilliant that's for sure
but that there are different
personalities as George is more quiet
JJ's like this little kid this guy's you
know his brain is constantly working I
could picture it oh he's wonderful did
JJ bring anything out of Lando as a
character that you didn't even realize
was there from the beginning well
there's a depth that he brought to this
character I think that I that wasn't
there before this is a little random but
do you know about baby Yoda how
everyone's talking about everybody's
asking me about baby Yoda I haven't paid
much too much attention it's I mean it's
an adorable Star Wars creature so we're
playing a little game with baby you see
them yeah I mean that's all you need and
then all of a sudden your heart melts so
in in line with the idea of a baby's
first something if you had the
opportunity to witness baby Yoda's first
fill in the blank what would it be so
baby Otis first I don't know words or
baths or birthday party something like
that I don't know when you're a baby
you're always exploring and it depends
on look at what you know you know
personalities of course it's a piece of
machinery right it's it's a robot so I
don't know if a robot's have
personalities yes they do and the in
Star Wars
yeah bb-8 is my heart for life but we
all start with a personality that we
acquire as we go through life we also I
think that we we carry with us a
collective unconscious we've been to
other experiences prior to this
experience so it depends on what his
what they make of that so I don't know
I'm just kidding like much too deep
there's some character I believe right
now he's a baby he's running around
trying to explore and try to touch
everything